the song uh have you ever seen the rain
was written by you of course
about the tensions in your band right
the fact that things were not going well
yeah i i kind of i perceived all the
attention and
it just looked like it was breaking up i
really did you knew
you sure felt that way did it come too
easily
it was well the the metaphor of course
you know of seeing
rain come down from a clear sunshiny day
yeah uh it seemed to be what we were we
were here we were we were
achieving all our dreams everything's
great wow you know instead of being
happy
we seem to be miserable when you wrote
the song did you tell the band this is
about uh no oh no no did they
pick up on it at all no you have your
acoustic guitar there
would you do another one for us i would
love to just you and the guitar
in order to sing it do you have to go
back to that in your memory about the
band almost breaking up is that how you
get the feeling when you sing it
uh nowadays i actually well it was a sad
song right
i actually think about my daughter
kelsey kelsey is certainly a rainbow in
my life i mean
she's inspired a few songs out of me
right so this
particular song has a rainbow in it so
when i'm
singing it nowadays i actually explain
that to an
to an audience it just makes it more fun
for me certainly
here we go
[Applause]
someone told me long ago
there's a calm before the storm
i know it's been
coming for some time
[Music]
when it's over so they say
it'll rain a sunny day i know
shining down like water
[Music]
i wanna know have you ever
seen the rain
[Music]
i wanna know but have you ever
seen the rain
[Music]
coming down a sunny day
yesterday and days before
sun is cold the rain is hard i
know up in that way for all my
time
till fury of a horn it goes
through the circle fast and slow i know
and it can't stop i
wonder
i want to know have you ever seen the
rain
i wanna know where have you ever
seen the rain
coming down a sunny day
[Music]
you